SCP-035 Vs SCP-106.
The Possessive Mask Vs The Old Man.
Which one of these two incredibly evil SCPs
would win out in a battle?
Let’s find out.
035 is a theatrical mask that takes over and
kills its victims with its powerful brainwaves.
It also leaks a corrosive black fluid that
breaks down human bodies.
This is something it actually has in common
with SCP-106, which also leaks corrosive black
fluid, in addition to being able to walk through
walls and drag people into its nightmare pocket
dimension.
We’d argue that the truly frightening outcome
here is not a fight, but an alliance.
If 106 was able to wear 035 and survive, the
result could be an anomaly with their combined
power set - All the terrifying abilities of
106, with added intelligence and mental manipulation
abilities from 035.
A true force to be reckoned with.